نحن هنا عند المعبر الحدودي الذي
يفصل باكستان عن أفغانستان
ويمكنك أن ترى ورائي الكثير من
مقاتلي طالبان يقفون هنا تحت
علم طالبان الأبيض وهو العلم الرسمي
عند هذا المعبر الحدودي الآن
ما لا تراه.  إذا أتيت
إلى هنا معي ، فهناك أشخاص
يدخلون إلى باكستان ، فهذا هو خط
الأفغان الذين ينتظرون الوصول إلى
باكستان ، ولكن يُسمح فقط للأشخاص الذين لديهم
وثائق أو إقامة باكستانية
بالدخول في هذه المرحلة وكان
ذلك بمثابة قاعدة.  لقد كان هذا في مكانه
لبضعة أشهر الآن جزئيًا بسبب
اللوائح المرغوبة جزئيًا لأن باكستان تقول
إنها لا تستطيع التعامل مع تدفق اللاجئين
الآن إذا نظرت
هنا ورائي ، يمكنك رؤية هذه المجموعة
هنا من الأشخاص المرضى جدًا.
تريد لفت انتباهك إلى
امرأة ذات مظهر جاد بشكل خاص مع صبي صغير
لديه نوع من الضمادات الملطخة بالدماء
على حجره
وهؤلاء الأشخاص يناشدون باكستان بشكل أساسي
للحصول على طبيب عاجل
تم السماح لبعض الأشخاص
بالذهاب
إلى المستشفيات ، لكن ما تقوله باكستان
الآن هو أن لدينا أكثر من
مليون لاجئ أفغاني ولا يمكننا ببساطة
التعامل مع أي جناح
كلاريسا آخر عند عزم الدوران ومعبر الحدود